My mom was a really amazing person.
She was the type of person that could take any mundane life event
and turn it into a party in about 10 minutes flat.
She was really, really into holidays,
and she could take our normal suburban Pittsburgh house
and turn it into all these magical worlds.
And not just for holidays that, like, everybody decorates for.
We had a special set of flags that were just for Memorial Day,
that were different than the flags that we used on the 4th of July.
Christmas was a really big deal.
We had a tree in every room, and every tree had a theme.
She liked themes.
I never had a birthday party that didn't have one.
There was the Victorian Tea Party,
and the fitness birthday party.
I'm an only child, what can I say?
I think she just really wanted everything to be special.
But growing up like this,
that also meant that our house had a lot of stuff in it.
If we're being honest, she was a pack rat verging onto a hoarder.
She had all the tendencies.
If she saw something she liked, she bought three of them.
She had all of these materials for projects that she never even started,
let alone finished.
She saved everything, like normal stuff that parents save, like schoolwork,
but then like old bits of wrapping paper and ribbons.
She never threw away a piece of clothes.
She had two closets and two armoires just full of her clothing.
And that was kind of her MO.
Like if you walked into our house,
you would never know that she had all of this stuff,
because it was all tucked away into closets and drawers, nooks, crannies.
The attic was so full that we weren't even allowed to go in it,
and it was all Christmas decorations.
So I, as much as I loved this celebration,
like I could just never wrap my brain around the amount of stuff.
Like even as a child,
I just didn't understand the point of having things that we only used once a year,
or that she would just buy and forget about.
So now I'm someone who compulsively cleans.
When I open my own closet and I see something that I haven't, you know,
looked at or thought about for a couple months,
it like immediately goes to goodwill.
I'm not super sentimental with things.
You know, my husband might get me a card and write a little note in it,
and I'll put it out and then find a way to like quietly get rid of it.
So growing up in this house,
I just, you know, I never could understand all the stuff.
I was just more pragmatic than she ever was.
She was also really sick for my entire life.
We had a lot of holidays in hospitals or when she was bedridden,
but that never really slowed her down.
You know, she always like dragged herself out of bed and got the stuff up.
And when she passed away, when I was 25,
it was sudden, but it wasn't necessarily unexpected.
So while, you know, my dad and I weren't really prepared for it emotionally,
we had had a chance to sort of deal with that mentally.
So that first Christmas after she passed away,
we decided we're going to do the thing, you know.
We tracked down the decorations.
We found as many of them as we could.
We put them all up and we had a whole family over
and I cooked my first turkey all by myself.
And even though she wasn't there and it wasn't quite the same,
it felt okay.
You know, this is the new normal.
We can figure this out.
And about a year after that, I got the phone call from my dad.
I'm going to sell the house.
You know, it's too big.
And I took this a lot harder than your average adult does.
It was the only house that I had ever lived in my entire life
from when I was born until I went away to college.
And I just couldn't imagine a world in where I wasn't going back to that house.
But despite my hesitations, this is what's happening.
So I go home to help him clean out the house
and immediately it is just stuff overwhelm.
I mean, there's 20 years worth of stuff here
that nobody has ever really gone through.
And I live in Brooklyn in an apartment.
What am I going to do with a formal dining room table
and like eight chairs that are so heavy I can barely lift them,
let alone an entire attic full of Christmas decorations?
And it immediately just made me feel like a pretty terrible daughter
because I knew the expectation was that I was supposed to keep all of this stuff,
that somehow one day I was going to have my own house
and I was going to fill it up with the stuff and our lives were just really different.
That was never going to be my thing.
So I'm standing there having this moment in the house
looking at this dining room table and my dad says to me,
you got to go clean out the closet in the bedroom.
In my house for my entire life,
this specific closet was always called the closet that eats everything.
And it was called this because if you lost something in my house,
no matter where this item originated from,
it wound up in this closet like that room in Harry Potter
where all the missing stuff goes.
It's like a series of pneumatic tubes like would connect the garage and the kitchen
and no matter where this item originated, it wound up in this closet.
And it would like lose a shirt and I'd be like,
Mom, have you seen my shirt?
Oh, well, did you check the closet that eats everything?
No, Mom, why would it be in there?
And she'd like open the door and pull out the shirt.
Is this the one you're looking for?
Just happened more times that I could count.
But the real reason that I was anxious about going into this closet
was because it was also where we kept all of the family photos
and the scrapbooking materials.
So I made a plan.
I was not going to engage with any of the stuff.
I was just going to sort the stuff
because nostalgia is the enemy of all successful cleaning expeditions.
So family photos, keep one pile.
Old unsent greeting cards, throw away another pile.
And that lasted for about five minutes before I'm knee deep in the family photos
going through every single one of them.
And I'm looking at pictures of us, you know, around that ugly table,
Thanksgiving and a bunch of, you know,
six-year-old girls in puffy dresses having a tea party
and photos of Christmas trees that were so beautiful
that they could have been in magazines.
And all that stuff started to get really real again.
And that is when I noticed this box.
It's just a normal cardboard box that looked kind of new.
So my first thought was like, oh my God,
here's another thing that she bought that she didn't even know that she had.
But I picked it up and the contents inside were like shifting a little bit
and it was heavy.
So I opened it and I look down and it is a box of greeting cards.
Okay, so she got the guy at Hallmark to give her the overstock for some reason,
you know, but then I noticed them and none of them have any envelopes.
And I thought that was weird.
So I picked up the first card and it was a first birthday card.
It was my first birthday card.
It said 2 Morgan on it.
And when you opened it up, it had slots inside of it
where you're supposed to put pennies from the year that the baby is born
and all of the 1983 pennies were still in there.
So I keep digging through this box and there's more first birthday cards
and there's cards from Christmas and Halloween
because who gives greeting cards on Halloween?
And Thanksgiving and birthdays and Valentine's Day
and cards that I had received just because or because we had a fight
and it dawns on me and it's apparent that this entire box
is every single greeting card that was ever exchanged
between me, my mom and my dad from the time that I was born
up until the fairly recent past.
And I just did not understand this box and it made me really angry
and upset because there was obviously something
that I was supposed to know about this box, something that she knew.
She was saving these things for a reason, but I didn't know what it was
and now all of a sudden here's this box of memories
that I am confronted with.
This is what I was so worried about losing in the house,
but now they're my responsibility.
And before I knew it, my whole body just started sort of reacting without me
and I panicked and I started to throw everything away just ripping things
and throwing them and I am weeping and that's how my dad found me
and he was like in a pile of greeting cards surrounded by stuff.
So I tell him about the box and we start to sort of calmly go through it
and he picks up a card and he looks at it and he says,
I remember getting this birthday card.
I had it on my desk for a while and then I threw it away.
I specifically remember throwing this card away.
So now we have this moment where we're laughing together
at this image of my mom like digging through the trash to save greeting cards
and it just dawned on us that we're never going to know the answer to this mystery,
that she's gone.
And I'm looking through cards and I see cards that I signed my name to
but that I don't remember buying and cards that have my name on them,
but that I don't really remember getting and without her,
without her logic and her magic, they were just stuff.
They were just her stuff.
The box, the cards, they weren't my memories to save.
They were her memories.
And she had just saved so much stuff that none of it was really special anymore,
you know, to me that the most special thing about this box was that
she had cared enough to save it in the first place
and that I got to experience that one more time.
So we each took a few things and ultimately we decided we could let it go.
We could get rid of the rest of them.
We took them to the recycling bin.
And the next day I went back to New York and I never set foot in that house again.
But I had this new sense of calm about the whole thing.
And in the back seat with me on my drive was a box of Christmas ornaments
and a card full of 1983 pennies.